van gol at saint louis in the clouds
who's mouthing a tennis keywords d east
of speech in the tragic night of 6
October 1996
rebels attacked our hospital at
the emirate the democratic republic of
congo
more than 30 people killed patients
beat in the links at close range
staff can not flee killed
cold blood
I could not imagine that this
was only the beginning
forced to leave the emirate in 1999 we
we created the panzi hospital in bukavu
where I work today as a young person
ecologist obstetricians
the first patient admitted was a
victim of rape who received a coup
fire in his genitals the
macabre violence knew no
limit
this unfortunately born violence
never stopped one day like the others
the hospital made a call after the
wire a colleague in tears implored if he
please send us quickly a
ambience
please hurry up so we
sent an ambulance
as we usually do
two hours later the ambulance is
income inside a little girl
from just 18 months she was bleeding
abundantly and was immediately brought
in the operating room when I'm
arrived the nurses while in tears the
bladder from a rash on the device
genital his rectum and is gravely
damaged by the penetration of a
adult
we pray in silence my god says all
that what we see is not true
tell us it's a bad dream
tell us that when we wake up, everything will be fine
but it was not a bad dream
it was reality is devoted
our new reality the republic
democratic of the congo
when another baby arrived I
realized that these problems could not
not find a surgical solution
but we had to fight against
root causes of these atrocities
I went to the village of the cases you
to talk with men why
you do not protect your babies your daughters
and your fans where are the authorities in
these villages to my surprise of
villagers know the suspect all the
world was afraid of him because he was
member of the provincial parliament and
enjoyed absolute power over the
population
for several months it reads me
terrorize entire villages he had
a style and fear years you have a
human rights defender who had
had the courage to denounce the facts
the deputies escaped without
consequence his parliamentary immunity
allowed him to abuse in any
impunity
these two babies were followed by
dozens of other children raped when
the 48th victim arrived we were
desperate with other defenders of
human rights
we seized a military court
finally these games they were
prosecuted and tried as a crime against
mankind
rape of bba cave where we stop
calls to panzi on May 6
the psychological and sexual future
reproductive genetics of cdb is
mortgaged what happened to kavumu
and which continues today in
many other villages in Congo such
that rapes and massacres to be blessed and
Kasai was made possible by
the absence of a state of law
the foundation of traditional values
it reigns impunity in particular
for the people in power
rape massacre torture
insecurity spreads the lack
of education create a spiral of
unprecedented violence
the balance sheets of these cases to the perverts and
organized was hundreds of
thousands of women raped over 4
millions of displaced people to
the interior of the country and the loss of 6
millions of visuals to imagine
the equivalent of the entire province of
the whole population of Denmark decimated
the peacekeepers the experts of the
united nations have not been spared
then I found death in
fulfilling their mandate the
mission of the united nations in republic
Democratic Republic of Congo remain
until these days so the situation
does not degenerate further
we are grateful to them
however
despite their efforts this tragedy
human being it pursues without all
responsible are not prosecuted
only the fight against impunity can
break the spiral of violence and we
all have the power to change the
course of history
when and why
we are fighting are just going
majesty your royal highness excellence
distinguished members of the Nobel Committee
dear madam nadia
ladies and gentlemen of peace
it is in the name of the Congolese people that
I accept the Nobel Peace Prize
it's up to everything
[Music]
it is to all victims of violence
sexual intercourse around the world
what gede 10 is taken it's with
humility that I present to you
raising the voices of the victims of
sexual violence in conflict and
the hopes of my compatriots I
take this opportunity to thank
all those who during these years have
supported our fight I think in
particular to organizations and
institutions of countries friends to my
colleagues to my family and to my dear
wife madeleine
[Applause]
[Music]
my name is dennis my mail I
come from a richest country in the
planet
yet the people of my country are among
the world's poorest the reality
troubling and that is the abundance of our
natural resources gold cobalt coltan
and other and strategic minerals
feeds the source war of violence
extreme and abject poverty in
Democratic Republic of Congo
we have all the beautiful cars
jewels gadgets
I myself have a smartphone these objects
contain mines and ray against ueno
often extracted under conditions
inhuman by young children who
are victims of intimidation and
sexual violence while driving your
electric car using your
smartphone admires your jewelry
think for a moment about the human cost
of making these objects as
that consumer the halves one can
make
[Applause]
as a consumer the least that
we can do
and insist that these products be
made with respect for dignity
human
close your eyes in front of the dramas
to be complicit it's not just
the perpetrators of the violence that are
responsible for their crimes
but also those who choose to
look away
my country is systematically looted
with the complicity of people who
pretend to be and our pillet leaders
for their ability to pay for
wealth lrgp loire foot at the expense of
millions of men of women and children
innocent abandoned in misery
extreme while the profits of
nominees ray was finishing up on the accounts
opaque of a predatory oligarchy
it's the end 20 years to the day that
the panzi hospital I see the
consequences of this bad
governance of my country
baby girl young woman mother grammar and
also men
and the guys have cruelly violated
often in public
a collective by inserting plastic
white or by introducing objects
blunt dallaire genitals
I was talking about the details
the Congolese people and humiliated
abused slaughtered for more than
two decades in the light and knowledge of the
International community
today today thanks to
new information technologies and
of communication
no one can say I did not know
not with these Nobel Peace Prizes
I call the world to be less and
I urge you to join us
to put an end to this suffering that
shame on our common humanity
the inhabitants of my country have
desperate for peace but
how to build peace on
mass graves
how to build peace without truth
nor reconciliation
how to build peace without justice
neither repair
at the moment I'm talking to you report to
the selfish mildew in the drawers of a
office in new york
it was written after an investigation
professional and rigorous on
war crimes and violations of
human rights perpetrated in the congo
this survey explicitly name
victims of dates places but elite
the authors it is report of the project
mapping established by the high commission
united nations human rights
describes no less than 617 war crimes
and crimes against humanity
and maybe even crimes of genocide
what is the world waiting for them to be
taken into account
there is no lasting peace without justice
but justice is not negotiated
let's have the courage to take a look
unbiased criticism of events
who have been raging for too long in
the Great Lakes Region
let's have the courage to reveal the names of
perpetrators of crimes against humanity
to simply avoid them
continue to mourn this region
martyrdom let us have the courage to recognize
our mistakes of the past
let's have the courage to tell the truth and
perform the work of the memoirs
dear Congolese compatriots let's have the
courage to take our destiny in hand
let's build peace build
[Music]
[Applause]
let's build peace let's build
the future of our country
together let's build a better future
for africa
nobody will do it for us
ladies and gentlemen annie skid the
paintings that I bumped you off
a sinister reality but allow me
to tell you the story of sarah
sarah was transferred to the hospital
of panzi in critical condition his
village had been attacked by a group
armed who had slaughtered all his family
leaving her alone taken hostage she has
been brought into a forest attached to a tree
naked sarah every day were undergoing
gang rapes until she
lost consciousness
b2c rape used as a weapon of war
and destroy of course sarah but
also his family his community brief
simply destroy the tucistes
on arrival at the hospital
sarah could not walk or even
hold up and could not hold back
nor her nice urine and that because of
the severity of his injuries
urinary genitals and digestive coupled with
an infection on added nobody
could imagine she would be a day
able to get back on his feet
yet every day that passes and the
desires to continue to live shine in
their eyes
every day that passes and it was she
who encouraged the nursing staff to
is not losing hope
every day that passes and sarah it's
was beating for his survival
today that's a beautiful woman
smiling strong charming sarah stood
committed to helping people and a lived
a story similar to his
it received 5 in US dollars a
allowance that our house transits
dorcas gives women wishing
rebuild their lives on the socio
economic
today sarah runs her little
business
she bought a small lot the
mozilla foundation ideas with tons
to make a roof she could get
to build a home
she is autonomous and very proud
to be autonomous his story shows that
even if a situation is difficult and
it despairs me and the determination with
the determination
there is always hope at the end of
tunnel
if a woman like sarah does not give up
what are we doing to do this and
of course the story says it stops
Congolese but there is sahara in
Central African Republic in Colombia in
bosnia oniam to anne iraq and in well
other countries in conflict in the world
at panzi our care program
holistic that includes support
psychological medical this economic sky
and legal watch worried even though the
road to healing is long
difficult
victims have the potential to
transform their suffering into power
they can become actresses of
positive change in society
this is the case already the city of joy
our rehabilitation center in bukavu
where women are helped to spread
their destiny to hand however they do not
can not do it alone and our role
is to listen to them like today
we are listening to madam nadia mourad
nadia your courage your daring
your ability to give me hope
a source of inspiration for the world
whole but for me especially the
Nobel Peace Prize which is ours
awarded today laura of value
real who if he can change
concretely the lives of the victims of
sexual violence
departure the world and helped bring back
peace in our countries
so what can we do
or what can you do
firstly it's our responsibility
everyone to act in this way and to act is
a choice is a choice to stop or not
violence against women
whether there is masculinity or not
positive that promotes gender equality
in times of peace as in times of
war
[Applause]
[Music]
to act is a choice to support or not
a woman of the protected where we defend
give up right to fight or not to his
sides in the ravaged country by
Conflicts
finally it's a choice to build
or not peace in the countries in conflict
to act is simply refused
indifference
if it is necessary to make war it is the
war against indifference that gnaws
our societies today
secondly we are all would be
vabs with these women and
their loved ones and we all have to
appropriate these fights including the
states that have to stop hosting
the leaders who tolerated or worse
use sexual violence to
access to power
states must
[Music]
states must stop them
welcome with the red carpets
and then all states must trace
a red line against the use of
rape as a weapon of war
a red line that would be synonymous with
political economic sanctions and
prosecution
to do an act is just not
difficult
to do a right act is not difficult
it's a question of political will
thirdly we must recognize
the sufferings of the survivors of
all violence against women
in armed conflicts and support them
holistically in their process
of healing
here I insisted on repairs
these measures that gives them compensation
and satisfaction the air allow to be
start a new life
that's a human right I call them
states to support the initiative of the
creation of a global fund for
repairs for victims of
sexual violence in conflict
armed
[Applause]
[Music]
fourthly on behalf of all
widows of all the heads of the orphans
massacres committed in the republic
democracy of the Congo and all
Congolese peace loving I call the
international community finally has
considered the project mapping reports
and his recommendations that the law be
said this is where it would allow the
Congolese people in crying his
dead mourn his forgive his
executioners exceed his suffering and
has projected itself serenely into
futures eventually after 20 years of
mergers of a hundred people the
massive displacement of populations
the Congolese people are waiting
desperately applying the
responsibility to protect
civilian populations when they hours
government can not or does not want
Do them
the people are waiting to explore the paths
a lasting peace
this peace goes through the principle plug
transparent free elections
credible and peaceful
[Music]
at work the Congolese people
let's build a state where the government is
serving its people and the state of
law
emerging countries capable of
sustainable and harmonious development where
not only in a democratic republic
of Congo
but in all Africa let's build a
state where all the political actions
economic and social issues are centered on
the human being and where the dignity of
citizens and restore your majesty
distinguished members of the Nobel Committee
ladies and gentlemen of peace
the challenges is clear and it's up to our
scope for for the sahara for the
women men and children of
congo
I send you an urgent call d is
not just give you the prize
nobel of peace but to put you
stand up and say together aloud
violence in a democratic republic
of Congo
it's enough, it's too much peace
now
Thank you
[Applause]
toll helped a lot
the open space on klose has lists at
elections but this plan
[Applause]
[Music]
anna freud is it specified speechi the
mythical charm city of francs manmohan
singh is sprinting to bella by nicolas
remy
[Applause]
at